crime is surging across the country but
the liberal media
they don't seem to care instead networks
like msnbc
claim to be shocked by the violence in
places like washington dc
and trying to find the positives
we know how safe and and wonderful our
city is that this is just a shocking way
that it was displayed for the whole
country to see
uh in a place that has been improving in
safety but we do have over 100
homicides here already this year and it
is really of concern
homicides are of concern and criminals
are emboldened during this crime wave
new video shows a man who has been
arrested
twice for attacking nypd officers
smashing a bottle
over one cop's head in an unprovoked
attack
that's the best concern you're gonna get
from an andrea mitchell again yeah and
she
did you notice how hard it was for her
to actually muster up any energy for
that
it was like she was talking about
constipation you know it was just like
it was it was
i mean there are a hundred homicides in
washington d.c
it's really important martha you know
did you see how quickly their concern
over the baseball
shooting came and went though it was
like you know if there were only white
nationalists or proud boys
not some damn gang shootout and by the
way that doesn't disturb don lemon's
dinner right because
these people are so far removed and i i
don't know i can't remember if i said
this before because we were talking
about crime forever
national news doesn't cover this because
it doesn't affect them local news covers
it because it's outside their doorstep
and the people that listen to local news
they care right they watch they want to
know what's happening on their street
but the cnn's in the world and we're the
anomaly fox news is like a local news
station for america
right we talk about all the problems
that are on your street
but the rest of the national news people
they act like you know it's like i got a
private car service my feet are never
going to touch the ground when i get out
of work
i'm going to go to the baseball game oh
my god i took my family to the game and
there was crime there
well that's the way it's been every day
for everybody you jackasses and
and i think you know what we have to do
we have to come out pro crime
because the only reason why the media is
not coming out anti-crime
is because we lead on pro-crime so if we
decide to be
to talk on behalf of the criminals and
laugh at the victims the way don lemon
and chris cuomo did you know blood good
blood crime i remember that
maybe they will change their story right
because it's disgusting
they're they're living through a
horrible time
we're seeing epidemic numbers these are
not this is not some kind of delusion
they would rather think about one day
january 6th
than any of the any of the savagery that
is happening
every day on our streets they whatever
happened to their
concerns about the elderly asians it
didn't fit their
their their race a narrative so they
don't even give a damn
anyway jesse they did uh talk
about asian hate crime because they
tried dependent on trump
i've heard this at this table where
the trump called it the china virus or
the wuhan flu and that was
the direct connection to elderly asian
women being attacked by
mentally ill men of color in places like
san francisco and new york that was the
best that they could do that was the the
most
outraged that they could muster because
it was about well they tried to make it
about drum
right i just can't wait till greg does a
pro crime monologue on the show
you go first with that correct i'll i'll
i'll follow right behind you on the
program you can do all pro crime for a
week
to see if it changes the public
narrative in the media yeah
i can see that working really well greg
um yeah artificial stances yes
artificial stances that's not a bad idea
so andrea mitchell
uh it's right now dc is on pace to set a
16-year
record for homicides but i can't even
talk statistics with the left they don't
listen to me you have to talk about
feelings and andrea
most people in washington dc feel
unsafe andrea probably doesn't because
she lives
in one of the most exclusive and
prestigious tree-lined
enclaves in the entire capital
surrounded by mansions with
wrought iron gates and armed guards and
dogs and she even lives near a
castle taken an actual castle is a few
doors down from her so she takes
the chauffeured car to the secure nbc
news studio
and she goes back and she doesn't go to
those neighborhoods so she feels safe
because
alan greenspan is very tough guy he will
protect her
and but that's not the problem i have
another problem with these people in
in in this city here this suspect's from
hackensack new jersey that smashed the
guy
i don't like people from new jersey
committing crimes in new york first of
all
but this guy's priors groping punching
an officer
uh two robberies terrorist threats
all these lazy da's they plea these
things down because they don't want to
waste time at trial
and this guy only served a couple months
then gets paroled and smashes an officer
in the head
if they would stop focusing on trying to
go after the cfo of the trump
organization for a tax issue
maybe actually lock up criminals that's
what people want
you know there's a police chief in
washington dc who got in front of the
cameras the other day when this little
six-year-old girl nya courtney was
killed
and he said listen to his community tell
me what you know
i know you know whose car this is i know
you know what's going on in your
community
this is not snitching this is saving
lives of other
children in your community and this is
the problem because uh
he's you know talking about it today
it's neighborhood on neighborhood crime
and so if if one person feels that they
have been offended they're
going over to the other neighborhood you
can tell from when you watch these
they're hits they're
they're direct intentional hits on
individuals
who are together for a reason and you
know this this
is this is so bad and to not report on
this to not talk about what's going on
in our cities
and you think you look at the lockdowns
you look at all these kids they're
teenagers half of them they've been
home for a year and a half because
nobody would reopen their schools and
they didn't have anywhere to go
and that there's a direct link i believe
between these things between the
lockdown and businesses being closed in
schools
there's too much time on everyone's
hands all this animosity that's built up
and it's rolling over
the top and it's ending up with these
children who are who are losing their
lives
what are the democrats going to do about
herald because again bail reform you get
arrested you're right back out on the
street that is one of the
biggest problems in terms of the wave
of crime that you've seen in all these
major cities particularly here in new
york city
new york's the biggest city in the
country new york voters democrats spoke
about nominating the candidate who spoke
toughest about crime who said he
returned gang units to the streets and
was against the funding of police
the most important voice in police in
the last 50 years i think is bill
bratton
he talked about community policing this
new mayor we're going to get here in new
york eric adams has talked about
precision policing
every big city that has a democrat is
mayor that has a police chief many of
them are african-american many of them
are democrats they're speaking up along
the lines that you raise martha
this is not a democrats coddling
criminals by no means you may have a few
people on tv who misspeak or who may be
taken out of context and i'm not saying
we did either with
with with uh with andrea but i'll tell
you this democrats don't
like crime we don't support crime and i
can tell you as an african-american
we want criminals hung in our
communities those that are dealing drugs
and gang members and those
shooting our children i will we won't
accept any african-american certainly
not a black democrat
is going to accept the notion that we
like crime or cattle criminal by no
means
democrat city council members defunded
the police
across the country so that is the
problem look
black mayors black democrats want to
fight crime as much as anybody else in
this country because often times it's
communities that are populated more by
us
that are affected they didn't want to
fight it last year when they signed all
those defunding
30 cities defunded the police but
washington dc
defunded the police to the tune of 40
million now their homicides are about
100 already in july
i'm not going to fight you i'll let the
numbers say the biggest
don't fight me the biggest city in
america new york city just nominated an
african-american former police captain
who stands who wants to bring gang units
back to communities to protect every
community not just
but every community we need it neither
can i can he stop the queen is de blasio
isn't that bizarre did you see when he
was standing behind him and eric adams
was like when i'm there
[Laughter]
sorry i'm not back here i mean talk
about a disappearing act
it's unbelievable it's been going on for
years you ran for president remember
yes hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else